I used to watch this perfect couple they  were the embodiment of true love  I want to start my life over again  I saw her I saw her from the train she  was she was quit this man just for a  second  is this her to a woman so can you tell  me where you were Friday night I was in  the city and then I went to visit my  husband you mean your ex-husband it's my  understanding that the woman who has  gone missing  who is his nanny hey Tom Hagen Rachel  why are you here because I'm helping  find Megan I don't think you're helping  anybody  I saw your wife with someone megan has a  therapist Xterra years old  what happened that night Donal tell me  the truth I read once that when a train  hits they can rip the clothes right off  of you you were seen in the area that  night did you murder Megan Hipwell No  just tell me what happened that night  why are you here  because I'm afraid of myself  a teacher once told me I was the  mistress of self reinvention  it's like having a secret